oh boy come here Luna's pretty fair with
her love like you know she's she's
always you know she always make sure
that if she's cuddling one of us that
she'll sort of like take a break and go
visit the other one that's Molly's dog
Elsa they both have very different roles
I think yeah I think Molly makes all the
rules not fun on that always shows up
with like candy and yeah so give her
scraps of my food and play with her on
the floor you give her scraps here food
no I mean no look you want more
definitely me I would have to disagree I
think she definitely loves me she sleeps
right next to me that's because you
smell like her her forever
me air stuck to her like glue anywhere
she goes trail behind her she goes to
the bathroom they wait at the door
yeah very nice
good girl come on Brittany like really
mean up your lawyer Rita get outta read
up yeah oh yeah stay yes yeah oh yeah oh
yeah this like this I really okay also
start
I'm not saying turning read up yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I don't have
anything I'm gonna go bye-bye
yeah pretty much what I expected
Rita that's a betrayal I'm a my boy
commute wow I was not that surprised
that she picked him she's very much a
daddy's girl she follows him around and
it wouldn't matter to either way yeah we
know she loves us both I felt kind of
cheated I still think she loves me more
Elsa didn't choose either of us she just
decided to run away
yeah we're not surprised she does love
freedom I love you the most
that's all that matters that's all that
matters
this is what I pay this is the only way
that you'll stay in place your big baby